it's great to be joined today by Gordon
lifer who's associate professor at the
Labor Education and Research Center at
the University of Oregon he's the author
of the book the one percent solution how
corporations are remaking America one
state at a time such an important issue
Gordon and I think many people in our
audience would of course be familiar
with citizens united and the way that
has impacted money and politics in the
United States but your book makes the
case that there is just so much more
beyond citizens united that is impacting
how corporations are increasingly in
control of different aspects of American
society and government let's start there
I mean what are what are some of the
ways outside of citizens united that
over the last five years we've seen a
move towards corporate power well I mean
the real I think everybody knows
citizens united let there be unlimited
money spent in politics but for one a
lot of I think too much attention has
been paid on individual billionaires
when the real money is with the big
corporations and what this book tries to
say is like so what are they doing now
that they're allowed to spend unlimited
money on politics what are they doing
with that insolence and what they're
doing unfortunately is trying to make
themselves richer and lower the wages
the benefits and the rights on the job
of almost everybody else both Union
non-union public employees private
sector employees they're working to
lower the minimum wage to do away with
the right to paid sick leave to cut
unemployment insurance a lot of things
that you know many people don't pay
attention to until you run into it in
your personal life but the really affect
many many aspects of our economic lives
and before we dig in more specifically
to some of the the instances that you
mentioned what metrics can we look at at
the economy level that reflects what has
been going on over the last five or even
more years along these lines I mean can
we look at certainly you mentioned the
minimum wage what about income and
wealth inequality I mean is that a macro
indicator that tells us how this is
affecting our society or what indicators
can we look at absolutely I mean America
has been becoming a more unequal country
for 40 years and I would say life has
been getting harder
for majority people in the country
slowly but steadily for about 40 years
if you look at the share of all income
that goes to people who work as opposed
to the owners or investors and companies
that's been declining and in 2010 hit
its lowest point ever for men 60% of men
now have seen their wages fall and
inflation adjusted terms over the last
40 years a quarter just to take the
minimum wage as in a long term
one-quarter of all people in the country
now work for less than what the minimum
wage was in 1968 and that means over a
hundred billion dollars a year that is
taken out of the pockets of people who
do the work and given to the people who
own and invest just because of the power
of their politics so there are a lot of
ways to measure it but it's a lot of
money it's a big impact in individuals
lives and it's a big impact for the
country as a whole let's begin - one
aspect of this that you talk about in
the book which is the privatization of
public services and this is one that
correct me if I'm wrong is particularly
noticeable at the state rather than the
federal level that's right I mean
everything that I've studied is at the
state level because Congress is mostly
deadlocked they pass a few big bills a
year but thousands of bills a year get
passed in the states and the states have
power over a lot of our land and the
corporate lobbies have more power in the
states than in the federal government
because nobody's really paying attention
most people are bored by state politics
but a lot of poor working-class and
middle-class families rely on things
like public transportation to get to
work or school or shopping at a fordable
rate Public Health Services from county
and city officials libraries two-thirds
of libraries are the only place in their
communities where you can get free
internet access and of course public
education and all of those things have
been cut drastically and cut not because
there was a budget crisis but because
the corporate lobbies pushed bills to
cut that and some of that is in order to
enable tax cuts for themselves and we've
seen for instance in Ohio and 2011 Ohio
eliminated full-day kindergarten for all
kids in Ohio and at the same year they
eliminated the inheritance tax with all
which only ever affected the 7% richest
families
in the state so we've seen a lot of
things like that taking money away from
public services that people depend on
into the hands of the most privileged
we've been talking about the so-called
tax proposal from Donald Trump which was
really just you know a page of bullet
points that that were lacking a lot of
detail but to the extent that it was a
plan one of the areas where it seems to
me that corporations have been hugely
successful in crafting the narrative
around taxation is the corporate tax
rate which of course is so drastically
different from the effective tax rate
paid by corporations talk a little bit
about that I mean we often hear from
corporations we have one of the highest
tax rates in the world in the u.s. at
thirty five percent corporate tax rates
but that ignores all of the mechanisms
through which the effective tax paid can
sometimes be zero or even negative
that's right I mean America has one of
the highest official kind of formal tax
rates on corporations and one of the
lowest actual effective rates of what
people pay at what corporations pay and
that has meant a couple things one thing
is defunding of public services another
is if you look over time of all of the
taxes that come in to pay for public
services how much is paid by
corporations and how much is paid by
individuals and families the share paid
by individuals has gone up and up and up
as corporations have grown big
departments of accountants whose whole
mission is to minimize how much they
contribute to public services and so you
get people you know individuals who end
up and kind of with anti-tax feelings so
they feel like I'm paying more and more
and getting less and less for it and
they're right their conclusion may not
be right but they're right that that is
what's happening it's happening because
the corporations are getting out of
paying their taxes let's talk a little
bit about populism I mean the 2016
election was interesting in that we had
populist sounding messages from both
Republican and Democratic candidates of
course Bernie Sanders advocating what I
would call progressive populism and
Donald Trump quite the opposite of
regressive populism but you've talked
about how corporate strategy has
actually been at least partially shaped
by the sort of populist sounding
rhetoric of elected officials talk about
that a little bit in what way
we see that well for one thing I think
that you know what does you know we're
in a time now when there's long term
downward a downward decline economic
decline it creates a lot of rage a lot
of insecurity a lot of anxiety and that
makes politics very chaotic and
combustible so you know I think that
we're at the point where the neoliberal
politics of saying well we're going to
have people who are investment bankers
or come from hedge funds but they're a
little bit nice so they care about
something is over I mean that's to say
nobody can ever win an election like
that but we saw both in the Republican
and Democratic parties that life is just
got too hard in America for people to be
satisfied with those kind of candidates
and then that sentiments of wanting
something to change of being angry can
split either right or left what we see
when you look at what the corporate
lobbies are doing corporate lobbies have
a lot of power but what they have failed
to do is to convince most people that
their ideas are good ideas so you see a
majority of both Republicans and
Democrats in favor of raising the
minimum wage in favor of a right to paid
sick leave in favor of fair scheduling
for people who are hourly workers
wanting smaller class size for their
kids and better trained teachers a right
to health insurance a whole lot of
things the corporate lobbies see this
and they're scared by it and I think
they try to do two things one is to get
the anger and anxiety to be channeled in
some direction other than done
themselves whether it's private sector
workers against government workers or
citizens against immigrants or however
you have it but the other is they're
trying to restrict our ability to vote
on things what you see in state after
state where they have the power is
corporate lobbies passing models at the
state level let's say we're going to
take away your right to decide at the
city level whether you want to have a
higher minimum wage or a right to paid
sick leave or something like that that
they're trying to restrict the amount of
the economy that citizens can have
Democratic control over how different is
corporate strategy depending on whether
the context is a left-wing or right-wing
populism I'd be curious to know because
we know that from the political point of
view you can have a populist message
that is a very right-wing message as
we've seen from Donald
which scapegoats the other it presents
him as the only and most direct path to
a solution or improvement to the problem
etc but if we step back from this and
look at it from the corporate
perspective can corporations do really
well whether it's under left or right
wing populism or does it make a
difference I think that they don't do
well under left wing populism and under
right wing populism they're walking down
this path but they're playing with fire
and I think they know it I mean it was
interesting that all of the big
corporate lobbies were opposed to Donald
Trump and basically every other
candidate except him was dependent on
corporate money and did what they wanted
and what they wanted which didn't work
the corporate design for the Tea Party
starting in 2010 was to have a mobilized
conservative base that was only
mobilized around anti-tax and
anti-government and economic Liberty and
get rid of all the social issues which
the money people thought were losers
politically so if you look at the Tea
Party platform a lot of people involved
in the Tea Party may have been
anti-immigrant or anti marriage equality
but there are a class form was only
about economic issues and that's what
the Koch brothers were trying to
engineer with the Tea Party and then
Trump hijacked it and made of both you
know in some ways more more populist on
economic messages and much more
right-wing on anti-immigrant anti-woman
anti-muslim all kinds of things and it's
dangerous and I think the it's dangerous
even for the corporate lobbies but the
more dangerous time I think is going to
come in a few years because Trump
basically ran on the promise of
providing decently paying jobs for
people without college degrees if that
dawns on people that that's not
happening in two or three or four years
his only move is going to be to double
down even more on whipping up white
nationalist frenzy I think by that time
the progressive populist need to have
organized enough of the people who put
faith in Trump for for helping
working-class people to move on to a
more progressive platform we've been
talking about the book the one percent
solution how corporations are remaking
America one state at a time and we've
been speaking with the book's author
Gordon Laver who's associate professor
at the Labor Education and Research
Center at the University of Oregon
Gordon thanks so much for talking to us
about
thanks very much for having me